vamos a recordar un poco algunas
definiciones de las funciones
trigonométricas que salen del círculo
unitario pero bueno antes recordemos que
su círculo unitario un círculo unitario
es justo este que tengo aquí es aquel
círculo que tienen de radio 1 por lo
tanto si tienen como radio 1 entonces o
esperan déjenme que me la herramienta
este punto de aquí es el punto 10 este
de aquí es el 0.1 ok
0 en x 1 en este punto de aquí sería el
menos 10 en menos 10 y este punto de
aquí sería el 0,21 y es un círculo
unitario porque cualquier punto que nos
tomemos en este círculo no se supongamos
este de aquí este punto de aquí va a
tener a una distancia al origen de uno
es decir que su radio es uno de lujo ok
pero en algunos vídeos previos hemos
visto que cuando nosotros queremos
definir funciones trigonométricas sobre
este círculo unitario lo que hacemos es
lo siguiente nosotros tomamos
a este eje de las equis fijo lo ponemos
fijo y ponemos por aquí uno de los lados
de este ángulo ok vamos a ponerlo más o
menos así
ok y nosotros nos tomamos otro de los
lados que forman un ángulo a partir de
este punto del origen entonces si
nosotros nos tomamos por ejemplo este
otro lado vamos a decir que el ángulo
que se forma entre estos dos lados entre
este y este de aquí le voy a poner el
nombre de teta y entonces decimos que el
punto en donde intersecta al círculo
unitario es decir este punto de aquí
tiene como coordenadas y aquí es donde
entra todo lo importante
acerca del círculo unitario en este
punto de que tiene como coordenada en x
por definición coordenada en x por
definición
el coche no detecta el coche no detectan
justo así era como nos tomábamos la
definición de este círculo
trigonométrico esto en el valor de x
mientras que en el valor de james la
altura de este punto es decir este valor
de aquí este valor de aquí tiene como
coordenada
seno de teta ok y justo así es la
definición de las funciones
trigonométricas dada este círculo
trigonométrico si nosotros hacemos
variar este ángulo entonces según el
punto del interceptemos a este círculo
unitario va a ser el coseno de ese
ángulo y el seno de ese ángulo y lo
padre de todo esto es que en vídeos
previos nos dimos cuenta de que funciona
para cualquier ángulo nosotros lo
probamos para la muda de 90 grados el
ángulo de 180 grados y algunos otros al
final nos dimos cuenta que esta es una
forma extendida de ver el soca tohá
ahora utilizando este círculo
trigonométrico lo que quiero ver en este
vídeo es encontrar la relación de la
identidad trigonométricas pitagórica y
para eso quiero que veamos este círculo
trigonométrico y recordemos un poco como
sacar la ecuación de un círculo cuyo
radio es 1 y está centrado en el origen
y bueno si hacemos un poco de memoria
tal vez en algunos vídeos has visto que
este círculo tiene como ecuación
x cuadrada x cuadrada ok más más
cuadrada más cuadrada esto igual al
radio al cuadrado esto igual al radio el
cual dado que bueno en este caso es 1 el
radio de este círculo es uno es igual a
1 elevado al cuadrado en radio elevado
al cuadrado ahora primero uno elevado al
cuadrado pues el mismo que uno así que
lo voy a quitar de aquí y lo segundo que
quiero que veas es que esta es la
ecuación de un círculo cuyo radio es 1 y
además está centrado en el origen
ahora si nosotros decimos que este punto
está en esta es la circunferencia
eso quiere decir que cumple esta
ecuación que tengo aquí y si cumple esta
ecuación que tengo aquí entonces podemos
decir que el valor del punto de este
punto de x y de james cumple esta
relación dicho de otra manera el coche
no el coseno cuadrado del ángulo teta el
coseno cuadrado de la mud o teta y pongo
el coseno cuadrado porque es justo el
valor que toma este
en x el coste no cuadrado estoy
sustituyendo aquí que es nuestro valor
de x de este punto de aquí que por
cierto está en la circunferencia más más
bien cuadrada pero en este punto ya
cuadrada vale seno de teta por lo tanto
va a ser seno cuadrado de teta ok esto
es exactamente igual esto es exactamente
igual a 1 porque está en este círculo
unitario y con esto llegamos a esta
igualdad que tengo aquí que por cierto
justo en el vídeo pasado habíamos dicho
que ésta se llama la identidad
trigonométricas pitagórica y pitagórica
porque salen de las funciones
trigonométricas y del teorema de
pitágoras y yo te había dicho que esto
es muy importante es la identidad
trigonométricas más importante porque si
nosotros ya sabemos no sé por ejemplo el
coseno de un ángulo con esta relación de
aquí ya podemos saber también el seno
del ángulo y viceversa y si ya tenemos
el coseno y el seno de un ángulo
entonces ya también tenemos la tangente
de un ángulo y todas
más funciones trigonométricas y bueno si
tú no entiendes bien o no recuerdas bien
de dónde sale esta identidad
trigonométricas del círculo unitario
también puedes pensar en un teorema de
pitágoras porque recuerda que estos
valores de este punto que tenemos aquí
coseno beteta seno beta lo que me
representan son los valores de xy de
james de este punto de aquí es decir que
esta distancia esta distancia que tengo
aquí es el coseno bueno de hecho va a
ser el valor absoluto del coseno de teta
y le pongo el valor absoluto porque
recuerda que esta es una distancia y
todas las distancias son positivas digo
en este cuadrante si estamos hablando de
una distancia positiva pero como este
ángulo puede estar definido para
cualquiera de estos cuadrantes entonces
podría tomar un valor negativo ok
entonces el valor absoluto del coche no
detecta es esta distancia que tengo aquí
por otra parte sé que esta distancia que
sube es decir esta altura es mi valor de
james y por lo tanto este de aquí es el
valor absoluto del seno de teta ok
el seno de teta y lo pongo en valor
absoluto porque recuerda que es una
distancia y debe ser siempre positiva y
bueno puede variar en cualquier parte de
este círculo y esto habla de un
triángulo rectángulo este es un
triángulo rectángulo cuya hipotenusa
vale 1 y bueno si nosotros no recordamos
como encuentro esta identidad
trigonométricas dado este círculo
trigonométrico entonces puede utilizar
el teorema de pitágoras porque yo sé que
el teorema de pitágoras me dice que uno
de los catetos elevado al cuadrado
ambos seno de teta en valor absoluto
elevado al cuadrado más más el otro de
los catetos que es el valor absoluto del
seno de teta más el otro de los catetos
el seno de teta en valor absoluto
elevado al cuadrado esto debe ser igual
esto debe de ser igual a la hipotenusa
elevada al cuadrado pero le imputamos en
este caso vale uno a uno elevado al
cuadrado que fue uno a uno elevado al
cuadrado y bueno uno elevado al cuadrado
es uno y lo que quiero que veas es que
coseno de teta en valor absoluto elevado
al cuadrado bueno pues esto es
exactamente lo mismo que el coseno josé
no cuadrado de teta porque al final sea
el valor que tome aquí el concepto de
teta si lo llevo al cuadrado siempre voy
a obtener un número positivo si a esto
le sumó el seno de teta en valor
absoluto elevado al cuadrado bueno por
cierto es lo mismo que el seno cuadrado
de t está ok porque el final siempre se
convierte en positivo sea negativo o
positivo el seno de tdt cuando el nuevo
al cuadrado se hace positivo esto es
exactamente igual a uno a uno y otra vez
obtuve la relación que yo quería esta
relación que nosotros hemos nombrado
como la identidad trigonométricas
pitagórica de las funciones
trigonométricas muy bien y de hecho es
justo por eso que se llama identidad
trigonométricas pitagórica porque sale
de un teorema de pitágoras
de hecho también esta es la base de cómo
definimos una circunferencia y cómo
encontramos su ecuación